and I want to talk a little bit today
about how I think that you can make a
bigger impact with people's skills
rather than simply with code and when we
think about people skills we think about
you know soft softly influencing people
showing empathy for our users having a
self-awareness knowing good
problem-solving techniques things like
that and you know being a good
communicator for example very important
but I want to get to some of the other
areas here as well so I think what's
really important is we need to be
thinking for users with users not for
them we want to be able to just do the
discovery and learn what we want to do
but at the same time we need to be able
to see the problem for ourselves because
too often we end up not really paying
attention to what the actual problem is
it's really important to be able to
communicate without using jargon at the
beginning of this talk I was asked by
the by the translators to see my slides
I said I promise you there's no jargon
in this whole talk it's a pretty simple
because I want to be able to communicate
to everyone I also think that your
interactions with others end up
mattering a lot more than the code that
you write when I'm looking at a new
system for the first time I normally
don't care as much how good the system
is I'm also trying to understand how
good the team is behind it and we do
this in WordPress as well in WordPress
when we're considering which external
libraries to add anyone get the joke
know a little bit when we're considering
what WordPress what what libraries to
add to WordPress we end up considering
not the technology but also all of the
other pieces how well does that team
communicate with us about five years ago
a few of us met with the creator of
backbone jf
specifically to talk about we want to
build a new media library the media
library that's been in WordPress for
about five years now and we want to pick
what at the time was the ascendant
JavaScript framework for about a week I
guess and we were trying to figure out
like should we go with this and so we
sat down with him and specifically
talked out our concerns and your
philosophies and how does all of that
make sense and can we does this make
sense to adopt we have very good
relationships with the jQuery team
jQuery is now more than half as old as
JavaScript it goes back a number of
years um and it's not the sexiest or
best piece of software out there but it
is something that ends up being really
great for just like doing things on the
Internet and so it's really important
that our philosophies lined up with that
project current conversations right now
about using reactor using view jf and a
lot of that isn't just which one is
better software but also how many people
maintain it can do we have conversations
with that
how are our interactions with those
teams what matters a lot more than
really anything else what I would also
argue is that not only do your
interactions with others matter more
than the code you write but also the
code you write can improve your
interaction with others and so let me
give you example you are doing code
review and you are constantly commenting
about coding style all you need an extra
space here this should really be broken
up into two lines not entirely sure why
you didn't put this if statement here
instead thing little things like that
and over time you're expending social
capital and potentially creating
negative interactions with someone when
you don't necessarily need to in go the
language go I have an entire specific
defined this is how go is formatted they
have eliminated
all arguments about formatting go
probably not true this some mailing with
somewhere but they've just papered over
all of that so you could imagine in your
continuous integration you're running
your unit tests or you are you are
making sure that it is styled correctly
you can now let a computer handle those
interactions rather than you a an
example that I had in government is that
I was back to the floppy disc story a
bit I was trying to make sure that all
these agencies were basically doing
their homework and I was the big bad
mean person who would send them emails
each day letting them know how far along
they were and the things that we needed
to do but at the same time I was also
offering to help but in some cases
sitting down with their engineers or
talking about their problems and I
realized they didn't like me all that
much because I would also be the person
that would hold them accountable by
sending them emails and saying hi you
didn't do all the things that we needed
you to do and so I sat down with them
and I said okay let's make a deal I will
stop bothering you if you can agree on
what metrics we need to track and we'll
take those metrics we'll put them in a
dashboard and then you can be mad at the
dashboard and not at me since I'm
working out really well they stopped
being mad at me
they started responding to me nicely now
instead of me being the big evil mean
person and then they had a single source
of truth for them to work off of this
ends up being really helpful rather than
arguing about like well what is causing
the problem well now we have a non human
telling us specifically what those
problems are and I guess I'll end with
this idea of as many times as possible
asking more questions I was dealing with
an authentication system at a specific
agency and an engineer said well we
really want to have system a and system
B talk to each other securely Nason how
should we do that and I said oh well
just I don't know like to a TLS or
something else like that just have them
talking like okay that works and I was
like wait it's not that easy what else
you trying to do
I said oh well user logs in here and
then they the data gets stored over here
and so we're just going to like share a
secret key back and forth I said oh
you're describing depending on the
specifics like a loss or sam'l like you
should use one of those and like yeah
maybe we might not and I was like wait
you're inventing your own an education
system this is not a good idea what are
you actually trying to do and after
asking enough questions I realized that
what they were trying to do is they
didn't trust the developers on the team
to actually write something to OAuth or
sam'l spec which point my question was
what makes you think they're going to
write anything else that secure either
in in the end a lot of times this comes
down to how what kind of people skills
can we really deploy we have this
hanging up at our office asking more
questions is actually a post-it note at
the end with a question mark at the end
of it we find that it ends up being
really important to ask why to listen
and to be able to respond very
deliberately and I'll close with one
final story floppy disk fax machines
some kind of pattern here about old
legacy government technology in this
particular case I we we were asked that
every day someone faxed a ton of a
spreadsheet to about 40 people and then
those people would all retype all of the
information this is not very good and we
said well you could email it and they
said well it's protected information and
we can't email it unencrypted I said oh
you could do what every other government
agency does which is encrypt the email
and send it and then send a follow-up
email with a password
and they said no our information
security people are actually pretty
smart they require us to use a fax
machine because it's secure not going to
touch that one and so at that point
we're like okay that's that's fine what
are you actually trying to do they said
well we're trying to eliminate the fax
machine I'm like are you you're trying
to eliminate the idea of typing up all
the information again right you're not
trying to eliminate the fax they're like
why are you recommending that we do like
optical character recognition I said no
your purpose isn't to stop faxing your
purpose is to stop typing what if you
sends the encrypted email and then fax
them the password so this is exactly how
the system still works two years later
thank you very much
[Applause]